pub
[Musique]
alors tu ne m'aimes pas ben alors
forcément c'est rigolo
je ne suis pas tant type pour croire dit
les aime grâce à je suis pas fixé il n'y
a qu'en ce qui me concerne que tu est
fixée oui je te dégoûte
non pas du tout juppé salle non plus
d'abord rien ne prouve que ça me
dégoûterait je fais trop propre à la
fata vendent pas si tu n'aimes pas parce
que tu connais ma mère on ne fait pas
rigoler alors je ne comprends pas nous
ne sommes même pas amis d'enfance ça va
tu vois comme ami d'enfance qui m'aurait
pas déplu c'est le comble alors qu'il
n'a même jamais eu envie de m'en passer
bon ben hammam répondre à temps j'essaye
de me rappeler laurent je crois pas et
quand tu vois un maillot mais ça ne fait
rien ah non j'ai pas dit ça
at mais je trouve extrêmement bien
proportionné proportionnée extrêmement
bien fait si tu préfères je vois ce que
cet hymne désir c'est déjà ça pardon je
te dis tu me désire c'est déjà ça
rocheteau 2 urgent nous désirons le
texte si tu préfères oui mais n'emploie
pas des mots pareils ça ne va pas
monsieur est choqué motus au bercail
mots chocs j'en ai assez vu dans ma vie
tu penses non mais des mots pareils le
nom de quoi je trouve pas ça bien au
toit de littérature veux tu je te plaît
physiquement oui tu me plais bien
les gens en vain oui les gens surtout eu
les jambes aussi les jambes surtout tu
aimeras les voir en ce moment dans le
salon quoi dans le salon où je comprends
monsieur voudrait aller jouer dans le
jardin et que je les lui fasse voir par
inadvertance veut succéder à vérité je
te trouve futile futile oui futile est
bien proportionné exactement et moi
avait-il je te dise la vérité
enfin la vérité sur moi ouais mais tu le
sais pas puisque tu m'aimes je le crois
tu que je t'ai vu tu me désire en tout
cas pas tellement je trouve cours
surpasse court sur pattes
ouais tu as de toutes petites genre mon
crois que c'est ton genou et pas du tout
c'est déjà ton derrière l'os est
possible
mon physique ne m'intéresse pas je suis
un intellectuel ça se boit à ce point là
ma parole si tu ne connaissais pas
josette tu croirais que tu es vierge
tandis que lundi que puisque tu connais
josette alia me bonheur depuis longtemps
que tu pense donc à ça à ce à quoi au
garçon et toi tu ne penses pas en fuite
ou même des choses plus intéressantes
dans la vie par exemple par exemple ça
ça les aspérités de l'écorcé terrestre
temps moins importante en comparaison
que celle d'une écorce d'orange hulu
voilà qui est intéressant
voilà qui tu seras utile plus tard tony
m'appelle pas tony je m'appelle antoine
et patois de vente et tony je voudrais
parler sérieusement sérieusement tu es
pour l'égalité devant l'amour n'est ce
pas c'est à dire jusqu'à un certain
point oui tu me l'a dit s'en fout et
bien évident que nous ne pouvons guère
refusé à nos compagnes certaines
libertés dont nous prévalons le préjugé
de la virginité et la jalousie sexuelle
et bien périmés a voulu le croire
il n'y a pas de doute bon admettons
alors alors voilà je viens te proposer
un essai loyal à l'américaine pourront
pas très bien tu mais c'est et si je te
plaît on se marie on fait ça en amérique
cours à vous remémorer ici si tu me
plaît parce que tu as peu près sûr
j'attends que quelqu'un d'autre
m'intéresse et toi tu retournes à des
séquences d'orange mais si on a un
enfant au printemps sur six sites
eux-mêmes supposons je ne vois pas
pourquoi on supposerait que des choses
désagréables
non il peut d'ailleurs noter viège
d'abord été entendus alors eh ben non
non ça ne se fait pas tu sédentaires on
n'est plus au moyen âge
l'histoire ensemble leur histoire vous
ne parlez pas du moyen-âge quand je suis
entré ah oui oui en effet du moyen-âge
vous n'avez pas accompagner votre pea la
conférence de cette année
d'ailleurs il me l'a pas demandé
d'ailleurs j'aimerais pape et j'avais
acura terminée c'était pourtant un beau
sujet ah oui lequel
la souffrance et nous vous savez madame
la souffrance et nous évidemment vous
êtes bien géré nous avons la chance de
ne pas encore l'avoir connu c'est pas
pour rien dans le parler vous êtes très
gentil nathalie antoine il faut aller
vous habiller mon enfant nos invités ne
vont pas tarder à arriver bien meurt
puis vous aurez la gentillesse et
remportez vos livres dans votre chambre
oui certainement meurs je peux rester
avec lui madame il s'agira dans la salle
de bain moi je vous y autorise s'il y
consent vous avez un très joli costume
merci madame je n'en dirais pas autant
de votre coiffure pourquoi excusez moi
ça ne me regarde pas mais je trouve que
vous avez tort tout coiffé de cette
façon oui ça vous donne l'air dur ça
avoue tire le visage ça empêche de voir
que vous êtes jolie les femmes le vois
très bien même les femmes au nerveux
comme vous et ça vous suffit
vous êtes une coquette et curieuse tu as
des tests oui mr nô momères certainement
mer depuis un an qu'elle est la femme de
ton père tu n'as pas pu s'y habituer non
elle m'exaspère même chaque jour un peu
plus après on rayonne ne trouve pas
naturel à s'occupe trop des domestiques
elle fait trop de visite elle fait trop
de confiture trop de cons titue et
christophe trop mal c'est moi même qui
l'a dit allez très gentils avec elle et
pas très gentille elle est trop gentil
tu crois qu'il n'est pas sincère
on écoute gens sérieux jusqu'au bout de
toutes mes forces et lui ton père ils
l'adorent ouais il adore mail l'embêtent
tiens tu crois que c'est une idée de luz
à la souffrance et nous la tête qu'il a
dû faire à cette conférence
j'aime bien qu'ils ont le loup a tempéré
tâches où il crie souvent mais c'est
assez dont je parlais de ta mère je veux
dire de ta belle mère ont ressenti comme
toujours a tout fait pour qu'on ne fait
pas de peine
en d'autres termes elle est guère mieux
mais c'est ce pauvre lui tout seul avec
de moutards relais 4 100 m à surfer
nantes 7 et c'était nous les plus
raisonnables mais chez 3com
whissell dans la vie bon c'est vrai
chicon lauture quelque part dans les
balkans
il a fallu que vous aimiez pour vous en
sortir quand elle est partie
bah ouais on a rigolé et elle tu penses
à quelques fois on ma mère on jamais
peut même pas imaginer quand j'étais
petit je la voyais dans un harem avec
des eunuques c'était une explication de
mon père probablement elle demande pas
aux non au contraire j'ai même souvent
pensé que c'était parce qu'ils m'avaient
destiné à être heureux que deux n'avait
pas jugé utile de me donner une mère
parce que tu te crois destine à être
heureux oui mais justement pas avec toi
c'est ce que nous verrons je ferais ton
bonheur que tu le veuilles ou non c'est
moi qui te dit tu vois pas comment
seront pas porté tous ses livres dans ma
chambre tu veux mais certaines le vrai
chef n'est pas toujours celui qui donne
des ordres à la lolo
oui
chaque mois en tissu sans rien un nom
comme une espèce de drôle d'odeur bobos
de gauche je mange mon parfum but
parfait mauvais cigare maintenant d'une
nuit d'arabie mais ben hmida ma vie ça
sera plutôt un parfum de plein air
amorcé sa peau qu'on veuille pas me bats
pour union culturelle ces photos femme
kate a fait tous ces frais tu vois
gagner moi pas si je crois au titre de
cette ut enlève sa naissance est l'objet
a pourtant demandé quelque chose de
discret même demandé de la discrétion un
coiffeur le fêter sais tu ce qui m'a dit
non
regarde moi ils jouèrent tu aurais
plutôt l'air dingue non ça va mais
oublie pas je suis ton père m'a fait
j'ai de beaux restes
très beau dommage qu'ils en aient si peu
dans les maquis et elle doit faire soit
pas vain m'a dit que si je faisais pas
attention je vais me lâcher de la tête
de veau gras déjà dans la famille mais
il est idiot comme ça m'embête tabac
obligerait à la jetée du grande
bouteille mais surtout à cause de ma
femme normale et aucun regarde quoi tu
veux je regarde mes cheveux attends chez
toi aller alors ah ouais ouais les
racines sont peut-être un peu faiblard
abate - abate - tiens on dirait qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui frappe alors je m'en fous
de ça c'est beau gros moments importants
a l'air bien racines sont faiblardes
meiway santé blâmer y en a beaucoup qui
effectuent leur entrée entre madame m'a
dit préparer les cocktails et apéritif
ici
ou est elle valable merci n'a survécu
d'entre eux mais monsieur ben spies
devrait ouvrir un peu la fenêtre
peut-être pourquoi je ne trouve pas que
ça mon serment le faire mais ça reste
super année tu voulais puisque sebo
l'air pur papoul à la cia mais faut
faire mais s'est fait tout seul
c'était lui a demandé la séparation ça
m'embête à cause de carole oui à ce que
vous voulez mais ce n'est pas toi qui
reste fair empoisonné les cheveux comme
carte n'est pas anodine et excusez moi
mais entre vous voyez pas me rendre un
petit service l'époque exide et sur la
souffrance bad
ah ouais parce que la souffrance et nous
la la conférence n'est pas allé mais moi
je crois que c'est que prouver quelque
chose d'assez bien qu'il ya peut-être
power faire la fête ah ouais mais je
vais développer cette idée souffrir
c'est mourir un peu
non c'est parti elle partira aussi les
parties officielles attendues façon non
non non au mieux les y retient pas lui
carrément au bois sur d'écouteurs le
comprends même pas que ce gentil parfois
prendre la peine de menti à tu vois par
contre toi
l'anru mais oui comment le situe
généraux jean a pas de nero je m'étais
tu sais bien la conscience de nos noms
et faire un écarté action je le regrette
il est temps d'aller t'habiller jamais
de la vie je n'y pense pas que dirait
notre invité mais rien du tout tut un
explorateur est ce qu'on aura chez les
sauvages a su mettre sa vie paru si
qu'est-ce que ça cet explorateur de
chiens l'explorateur pas celui ci
monnayent destin voyageurs c'est même un
ami d'enfance d'anciens dont juin par et
il l'a eu des femmes de toutes les
couleurs lindigo à la feuille morte
nathalie est une jeune fille d'un grand
bal à prévenir cette petite fille je
n'ai rien à craindre si amoureuse
d'antoine nathalie ben raisons de
l'aimer battant m appareils plus et
qu'il tient de son père j'ai tout fait
mme louise art mon fils m'appelle loulou
c'est ma femme qui me dit pas aux plus
jeunes familles
moi je suis bien content d'être père
mais je suis aussi bien content de pas
et de se dire alors à belmont nous loue
le boulot c'est gentil ou à la rigueur
chéri situe prêts à nous allier être en
retard antoine va aussi nathalie je suis
les ennuyer que nathalie lambert qui a
peur de rester seul avec moi au
contraire je trouve que je ne suis pas
assez souvent seul avec toi tu crois
qu'elle est vraiment amoureuse d'antoine
des gosses je me demande quand on est
jeune l'amour c'est de faire croire
qu'on est déjà des grandes personnes
quand on est vieux c'est faire croire on
a encore des enfants
j'ai des choses que le ser plâtre mais
je ne fais qu'à et intelligent puis
j'aime bien j'aime bien la pas en avoir
l'air qui est vraiment allé chez
chaillou target je suis trop intelligent
700 dans l'équipe tient tout à fait je
suis prêt je prépare une grande elle
vouloir des apps rue de l'armée dieu n'a
rencontré personne le connaissant ça
rassure toi j'ai au moins quatre témoins
d'ailleurs quand je suis arrivé chez lui
une petite promenade
jusqu'où vous étirez vous allez jeter un
gros chien et je suis revenu c'est bien
vrai mais dit douter que tu me fais une
scène de jalousie attend de voir assez
bien tu vois ça une femme doit fermer
samedi la deuxième son mari de ma femme
de fait remarquer qu'il ya d'autres
devoirs plus agréable donc tu n'atteins
qu il est il est vraiment si bien le
trouver
je te dis pas dire eh bien je dis tu te
dis juste un bonjour alors s'il est
tellement dangereux pourquoi était-ce
nathalie que tu mettais en garde est pas
moi toi oui moi on n'allume pas un
iceberg
qui sait à part de coquetterie s'il te
plaît ce n'est pas de la coquetterie
en effet c'est de la provocation tu sais
très bien que depuis un an que nous
sommes mariés personne n'a même eu
l'idée de te manquer de respect c'est
vrai et puisque nous sommes sur ce
terrain je t'avouerai comme moi même je
le commence à te respecte et presque
autant que les autres
j'ajoute que tu coquetterie dans la
conversation sont un peu déplacé que
c'est inutile de s'énerver parce que tu
n'as pas totalement fait que tu dire
c'est de même pas c'est tout de même pas
moi qui ai eu l'idée de faire chambre à
part non je dis que je suis fatigué mais
pareil j'ai besoin de ménagement
possible et c'est que même pour moi cela
me donne quinze jours par mois non bon
ils n'espèrent de l'institut général les
15 autres en danger la mer passe pas mon
temps couché comme toi et couché
inutilement pas inutilement du trust
trop c'est ça qui te fatigue pas la
pudeur bombe c'est très bien le plus de
moi je mange prie pour contre la pudeur
ou la mienne ne faudrait pas abuser des
meilleures choses quoi hier encore je te
fait quelques allusions discret de
discrètes une paire de baffes il faut
croire que cette disquette les a pas
comprises ils doivent croire ce
débilitants bande annonce et
recommandait que tu recommences à
recommencer une jolie c'est une pense
donc qu'un seul la tyrannie de la chère
au monde était vraiment un homme qui
aime ne peut pas être dépravé jamais
c'est bien connu est fier
[Applaudissements]
un très joli votre coiffure n'est ce pas
c'est ce que nathalie mme disette
personnellement je la trouve horrible je
la trouve isbergues et lassitude
générale
l'institut 'general mes compliments
ouais bah c'est parce que tu crois mais
vous n'êtes pas prêt naturellement moi c
est ton ami je ne parle pas de votre
europe comme elle sera noir aussi on ne
verra pas la différence et pas seulement
les journées pour maximum valeur du nord
d'où il tout seul dans son habit parce
que ça soit moi restons aussi tu crois
que ces plaisanteries sur son mari à
muscles elle même mais moins de joseph
lui les trouve tordante bons résultats
il est bien trop content d'être idiot
c'est bien que sans ça je n'aurais
jamais épousé dit pendant qu'ils
allaient polanski tient entendus pour
mercredi pour mercredi
je pense la nuit gilbert première année
à joseph et qui passera vraiment la nuit
si c'est comme il ya quinze jours
bien qu'un jour tu ne rentreras pour le
petit déjeuner peut-être même pas non
car son nom on me dit tu vas pas refuser
sa toyota n'ait aucune raison fait on
appel à tafalla ça il va me dont plaisir
laputa première fois c'était à l'usan
c'était une plaisanterie mais la
deuxième ce serait une des chances
mon rythme a baissé de 1,6 et entendues
alors c'est entendu des jeux passe la
nuit chez eux mercredi
ce n'est pas plaire délégués vont mourir
tellement discret c'est exactement comme
ça devrait plutôt plaisir de la
débarrasser un peu fatigué ce matin vous
devriez la conférence est qui vous
remercie mais je ne sais vraiment pas ce
que la maison deviendrait sans moi comme
vous voudrez je vais voir comment ils
ont disposé les cartes elle m'agace je
le vois bien c'est ce côté fourmis
qu'elle a toujours arrangé à travailler
à faire quelque chose
une vertu elle exagère ça peut être
embêtant parfois ça c'est alors le pire
c'est qu'on dirait que maintenant il
veut devenir l'aide c'est que toi sur je
l'assuré cette robe c'est pas naturel
c'est pas très naturel en effet c'est
drôle tu l'aimais bien longtemps oui je
l'aimé bien mon mariage
depuis que je suis femme elle m'inquiète
et toi comment tu rêves où tu ne
l'aiment pas il adore alors explique moi
cette histoire de mercredi j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'histoires crédit c'est très
simple sanaa
d'abord qui est ce mercredi colette
collège ventadour
pourquoi je te cause de carol c'est elle
qui te le demande et non un timide voire
ya certaines choses que je suis juste
pas eu si j'ai vraiment une femme
tellement épatant on va diminuer
tu en es là je t'assure que pour une
femme comme nc diminuera les invités ou
l'aller fuyons j'ai vu par la fête
seriez des patronats t'es pas bien
regardé les toits les cheveux avant
baltard marquettois on aurait fait des
choses pour joseph
si monsieur vais attendre l'instant
merci
[Applaudissements]
en cuir
platt mademoiselle
le dîner et on habille c'est monsieur
qui s'est trompé ah bon
[Musique]
monsieur monsieur je suis au gendre
joseph losserand de vendre en chanter ah
ah le salut arabe à le voir mais cet
explorateur bien connu pour être sûrs
c'est beaucoup dire bien connu en tout
cas je serais plutôt explorateurs que
bien connu là bas si on ne rit pas on
sait que les huîtres à lui le dîner tu
es bien pour 8 heures pour bitter oui
c'est un peu tôt pour vous mettre
l'europe en heure nous autres on afrique
mangions que nous avions fait notre
dîner à ce pays magnifique
je les comprends qu'ils dont les femmes
peuvent attester
je sais qu'il me parle le lot me l'a dit
de la digos à la fin du mois
merci l'attrait de l'inconnu et oui le
parfum de la vente et le 118 moi même si
vraiment ce dîner qu'il faut tuer avant
de manger c'est épatant
non mais tu es fou tu veux en savoir des
histoires de chasse vous confondez avec
les comme ils voyagent mille pardons
alors les femmes vous la raconter
l'afrique l'asie en général elle est
mieux d'asie avoir loué la grande
muraille dalaï lama les cerisiers en
fleurs et ça suffit mais non c'est pour
créer une ambiance donner un peu de
mystère et à ton écoute et vous me
gênait beaucoup à nouveau volé un truc
comme ça vous êtes il reste tellement à
leur fusion comme il avait un truc
hélas oui là je lis les libdems n'en
voulait vraiment bien sûr que non c'est
bien là le difficile je lis ce qu'on
attend gerry's la gamme avec vous et ça
je cherche devine je pose des questions
jusqu'à ce que j'ai compris ce la tête
difficile
une exploration que mieux vous parlez
aussi de l'avenir il faut bien et vous
êtes tombé juste oui deux ou trois fois
ce que je lui ai alors alors voleurs
deters voient un nouvel amour dans votre
vie un homme grand pro très jeune
mystérieux et qui a beaucoup à y aller
oui mais ce qui est fait mais presque
cela n'est fait ça suffit il a tellement
intéressé c'est pour vous renseigner
d'où mon idée vous verrez encore un truc
oui a le meilleur l'un fait à aa
ces jeunes femmes que mes profs à
laquelle vivent comme je vais vers elle
et je lui dit d'un air bizarre
madame il me semble bien vous avoir déjà
vu quelque part
c'est tout attente d'un air bizarre
madame et me semblait bien avoir déjà vu
quelque part c'est incroyable le nombre
de femmes qui ont un quelque part dans
leur vie alors après ça elles sont
avoués non je ne dis pas ça non le chant
reste ouvert à l'initiative personnelle
mais néanmoins il me paraît bien sûr pas
qu'on puisse faire tant de choses avec
quelque part voulez-vous que j'ai c'est
sûr madame n'ont jamais de la vie c'est
ma femme regarde y'a rien fait monsieur
salvador ont chanté mon père m'a
beaucoup parlé mais voilà que salvador
qu'il voulait faire l'expérience sur toi
non en tout cas sûre elles doivent
intéresser demain j'aime beaucoup les
expériences on s'embrasse
ils ont comme ces rues bon bah si nous
devons nous attendre et en faisant le
tout de suite j'ai promis à mon fils ça
serait pas les dîners de souvenirs je
ferai de mon mieux là antoine va bien
comme tu es en tomate il ton fils à
l'école à notre ami salvador bonjour se
nomme sagement la pierre soit bon c'est
pas faux j'aurais dû me souvenir
l'histoire des pommes de terre les
pommes de terre
comment c'est toi qui me l'a raconté
julien produits d'histoire le jour où il
était au restaurant avec toi et où le
garçon a demandé faut-il redonner aux
petits encore un peu de pommes de terre
et alors ça sert l'histoire et club ci a
demandé dit papa comment est-ce qu'il a
su que j'étais un enfant
ah ben c'est joli ça donne maintenant
avoir oublié ça j'aurais perdu ses trois
jolis mois tu l'aurais pas oubliée si tu
l'avais dit ça monte très probablement
inventé devient possible
bon je vais m'habiller à voici ma femme
maryse madrid et wilson amis qui me
donnait quelques prestige natalité
camarades de mon fils
camarades c'est une façon de parler
j'avais déjà eu le plaisir dans notre
voie vous voyez me fais lui dire la
vérité tout de suite il va se faire des
idées
le dîner est bientôt prêt face avant une
demi heure on pourrait peut-être voir un
petit quelque chose
c'est très rigolo
qu'est ce qui est rigolo l'histoire les
pommes de terre
à l'échappée j'ai beau être habitué et
effrayant l'eau oui mais oui mais de
l'eau un boyau et ouailles ont attaqué à
sico louis
un autre méthode la plus mauvaise langue
de la ville admirateur de ma femme on
chante et on chantait le mans battu
reptile a offert à murray il n'oublie
pas aussi mal voyants ben voyons on est
bien étonné du lapin pas m'étonner
c'est une saga met des mots sur sa
valeur moi je vous ai dit quelque chose
de la diva même ça ça ne m'étonne pas il
me disait qu'il lui semblait bien avoir
déjà vu ta femme
quelque part c'est vrai puisqu'il le dit
mais ça c'est pas une preuve et vous
l'aurez été vu alors je te dis pas que
je les ai vus je te dis que j'ai eu
l'impression de l'avoir déjà rencontré
très bizarre voilà des séries grâce à
son design moderne
il al'impression de ta d'ivoire et
jambes quelque part vous avez bien
besoin de dire ça oui j'ai cette
impression en effet malade
vous m'auriez vous rencontrer il sait
pas il a tellement voyagé ensemble
je ne crois pas j'ai ramé vous ne
rassemblez à perth c'est pourquoi je
veux permet d'assister état désastreux
paul cattier et doit alors que les
savoyards ont pas du tout bête et moi tu
te trompes
ça m'aurait étonné aussi tu n'es jamais
en france ça n'a jamais quitté la france
vous n'avez jamais quitté la france
adresse vous at elle dit mais on
pardonne tout proche soit pas écouté
il compte avoir déjà vu c'est par
exemple je lui ai répondu je ne compare
pas son nez si ça réussit pas toujours à
ce que fois
tout s'est passé par tellement race et
histoire de ressemblance
moi j'avais un copain battu l'inconnu il
avait un sosie comme ça un type
impossible une espèce d'escrocs à maître
chanteur le pauvre chaussin pourraient
pas rentrer dans un restaurant sans
recevoir des claques on s'excuse est
toujours après les gardes et avec
l'egypte c'est vous dire que l'histoire
n'est pas extraordinaire femme qui
semblait doute je me suis mon petit
bolide et areva a besoin de commencer ça
ton avis il n'est pas nerveux s'est un
peu énervé on n'y a pas de quoi aussi si
je t'assure ça m'est arrivé une fois
avec un type lui c'était yokohama
il prétendait que nous étions intime à
yokohama suis jamais allé à yokohama
nini ailleurs du reste le plus mal je me
suis allé c'est bruxelles on s'est
engueulés chanliau coma pendant trois
heures mais à la fin il m'a dit vous
avez raison mon ami était plus grand que
vous d'ailleurs ce matin anglais quand
c'est pour dire on ne devrait jamais te
laisser commencer
et pour carol dit qu'elle n'a jamais
quitté la france
mais si anodine ce pop n'a pas fini avec
cette histoire je peux aider à répondre
non non tu n'as jamais quitté la foire
non je ne veux pas pourquoi mais
pourquoi du pourquoi vous le dis tout ça
alors nos prières non je vois pas le
rapport
joseph hernandez et joseph le mercredi
je bonjour d'aprés c'est possible c'est
pas possible c'est certain mais c'est
peut-être certains je dis ce n'est pas
tout ce que tu dis moi c'est pourquoi tu
m'as dit centre pourquoi y avait une
autre raison
mais n'est pas du tout bon parlons
d'autre chose mais pourquoi moi je vois
ça n'intéresse pas nos invités du dessus
mais chez moi ça m'intéresse autant
marqué on peut compter de cette
conversation mais celle-là m'intéressait
pas un reptile évidemment je vais tout
vous dire pourquoi
si j'avais remporté d'affamés l'heure
qui suit je serai encore plus
catégorique que monsieur salvador mais
on n'a pas permis à l'essai salvador
d'être catégorie à cause de vous j'en
reconnaître n importe qu est ce qu'ils
ont mais c'est un m vielh admirateurs
comme le rsa tout en tant que les
opérateurs
j'ai vu naître histoire de yokohama tout
à l'heure je n'ai pas conclure vous on
peut vous comprendrez que n'importe qui
n'importe qui ne savent pas merci je
vais te fâche pas dans la tête
finalement classé cas les moyens aux
moyens regard ordinaire c'est une
parfumerie ans tandis que madame un
regard unique
je ne pensais aussi mais il faut croire
que non puisqu'on la retrouve pas unique
c'est bien le travail et monsieur sympa
de c'est bien beau la vie unity oui on
peut aussi vous avez vu ce regard unique
ont remis à l'itb on jamais alors bon
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas en italie en
europe
non non ce n'était pas en europe s'est
dit vraiment n'importe quoi dans votre
séjour au mexique a pu travailler pas
très fixées elles n'ont pas très pointu
font valoir une autre chose qui arrive
en dommage que nous n'ayons pas été au
mexique leur donnerait bien dire que tu
le saurais si tout est ce que je dis
pendant deux mois j'ai organisé la vente
de la chaussure c'est joli bar à ne
savoir qu'en faire il ya des femmes
juniors n'a pas y'a pas mal d'astek à
qui je dois les excuses aux jeux pas
contre eux voté moi non plus si tu
devais comprend ce que je dis il ya
longtemps que j'aurais renoncé à la
parole
je me suis mis en habit pour entendre ça
un cocktail si ça m'aide à me faire part
de si jolis me remets ma tournée par que
mademoiselle à de très jolis ma à aa
nous y voilà
nous y voilà où nulle part il ya toute
une réflexion comme sa réfection
quand on te dit nathalie à de jolis ma
la première réflexion qui deviennent
d'excès nous y voilà non c'est donc on
en fait pas tout de même un peu
attention
hier je te dis bien au musée voir un peu
de peinture tu me réponds je peux pas je
suis en deuil
ben c'est agaçant nous on a eu du mal
aussi habituer mais comment veux tu que
salvador sache ce que tu veux tu jaloux
quand on comprend que je rentre maman
s'il vous plaît vous avez une ligne de
chant ce minable voulez-vous me rendre
ma main si vous avez fait donc y voyant
la bonne aventure est formidable tant
mieux pour lui ne voulait pas que je
vous dise à bonaventure
non parce que je n'ai rien à apprendre
je sais où tu 7 ou 8 mon passé mon
avenir c'est antoine
il aura fallu le lui dire tout de suite
tu prévois tout comme d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs il finit pas de s'habiller
antoine schall il cherchait sans doute
ce qui l'attend à les voir mais n'est
pas tellement filière vous voulez savoir
votre fortune à mon retour au chaos
je pense quoi déjà tellement chaude en
province
si je sais ton avenir nous n'aurons plus
de surveiller la bonne parce que tu
comptes surtout l'avenir compte à
distraire oui tout paris il ya toujours
assez bien d'autres réflexions
il ya toujours de voir le rythme est
vite fait explique leur a clairement je
dis non euros
à la foire aux non non je suis trop
vieux jeu depuis à celle à venir ne
sauve pas curieux nous avons une chance
unique de pouvoir apprendre votre avenir
personnel en profiter mais il doit alors
moi encore moins que les autres
madame non plus vous voulez me dire
qu'on est venu intensité prive des
bribes seulement je peut que soulever un
coin du voile avec vous le retrouve
c'est en quelque sorte
prête pas attention vous allez les
asiles d'aliénés vont se disputer ma
clientèle fortunée mon avenir une
seconde
oui oui oui oui à votre autre main s'il
vous plaît c'est mauvais non je m'étais
trompé
voulez vous piquer la balle légèrement
comme ceux très content d'être là sort
très bizarre aussi bizarre que ça voyage
ou factures à la nuit c'est plutôt bon
signe de voir l'influencé de la lune
très marqué elle n'avait 10 venus en
très bonne position alors 20 minutes
unique de coeur comme j'en ai sans doute
jamais vu ce qui veut dire en langage
courant
vous êtes une femme étonnante madame
c'est dans sa main vous avez vu et vous
aurez une vie des plus intéressante à
m'attendre
alors ne te trompe je ne sais pas pour
celle qu'elle aura mais pour celles
qu'elle a eu le plus intéressant je
t'assure on n'est pas difficile parce
que être orpheline à 17 ans est
recueillie par une vieille tante et
vivre avec elle près de 10 ans à l'angle
ici aussi c'est la province est entendu
par via des fleurs et du soleil mais
langue parce que c'est quand il ya bien
qu'elle a eu une vie des plus
intéressants dans une tendance à me
faire rigoler il mon avenir mais madame
n'est pas resté tout le temps à langres
non quand je me suis remarié a pas car
je l'épousé elle était là depuis deux
ans c'est drôle dans sa mort on dirait
qu'il n'y a pas que l'on roule que c'est
mon passé savannah est bon pourquoi
dis-tu ce oui c'est par le passé que
j'explique la vie votre numéro de forces
est nettement meilleur que l'on je peux
vous dire des choses vous vous auriez un
enfant peut-être 3 offrant quelques
précisions bienvenues en a trois dans
votre main de dix ans trois enfants ça
va faire cinq relais deux autres peuvent
indiquer aux toiles et fernand aura
alors alors peut-être pas du tout
pourquoi parce que le troisième c'est
peut-être moi même pas apple moment
et ce sera comme ça pendant tout le
dîner vous voyez autre chose oui oui des
voyages beaucoup de voyages et xl où je
vais vous le savez mieux que moi a dit
très justement vous avez aussi des
dispositions artistiques vous chanter ça
j'aurais piano avec un doigt je ne
comprends pas les confitures c'est peut
être de là alors le reste je ne peux pas
le dire parce que nous ne sommes pas
seuls mais la mémoire nous pouvons vous
laissez pas la peine c'est moi qui ai
entendu que dire non mais ce sont des
choses c'est intime
comment tu connais les choses à un type
sur ma femme alors qu est ce que vous
allez je vous dis non non je n'aurais
pas la sottise de profiter de votre
autorisation
il est peut-être beaucoup d'hommes dans
ma vie je dis cela ont battu à mort d'ib
heureusement mais j'ai compris vos
allusions vous savez les voyages les
dispositions artistiques enfin c'est
assez clair
mais pour quoi vous en tenir l'iphone
achevée vous avez maintenant un
excellent prétexte pour comprendre
l'avarié a confiance en moi il faudra
être plus clair nova tunes je ne
comprends pas ce qu'on attend pour
servir se dirait by d'ailleurs raison
est un peu nerveux
tu m'excuseras j'avais à faire après
guinée fait pour l'idiot doit maintenant
en 2008 elle n'y pense pas excuse moi tu
as peu ta faute je l'avais rien
d'extraordinaire l'aura compris en
option la voilà voilà moi je comprend
rien et elle comprend trop
vous auriez aimé lui parler de son passé
avec le patient on s'arrange aux jeux
authentiques l'avenir et jamais
suffisant pour moi elle n'a pas digéré
le coup des trois enfants bon tu n'as
jamais dans la vie qui inquiète vraiment
aussi et qui s'y connaissait un peu
mieux vous soit dit en passant sur le
troisième il disait je ne peux rien dire
de sérieux sur l'avenir mais si vous
voulez c'est sur votre passé que je vous
apprendra des choses dans malawi c'était
pas mal on connaît bien son procès tout
de même propres dont je peux te dire
exactement tout ce qui m'est arrivé
depuis l'âge de 6 ans c'est possible
mieux que ça je peux dire combien de
bêtise j'ai fait dans l'hélico 27
exactement
j'ai compté je ne dis pas le contraire
mais tu te rappelles pas tous également
tu ne sais pas du tout les shows aussi
tellement importante pour toi
le jour où tu auras besoin de souvenirs
c'est moi qui en ai des souvenirs
qu'est ce qu'il y en avoir des choses la
cohorte extraordinaire c'était bien à
colleville n'est ce pas on a parlé sous
vireuse
oui les choses qui vous viennent
subitement propriété vont oublier ainsi
moi il m'est arrivé une putin 22 ou
trois ans quand j'étais au mexique une
aventure avec une petite femme tombait
écoute par fernand et acapulco où je
passais un soir entre deux avions alors
des copains m'avaient emmené au caf'conc
rejoindre leurs petites amies
il avait dit que j'étais à plat rond un
bar ou un attaché d'ambassade
il faut que ce soit plus games avait
présenté à une de leurs copines eu une
ghost chanter tu vas comprendre cette
petite gelée vu six heures en tout je
serais incapable de dire comment elle
était fatiguée elle était brune ou
blonde et huit jours après j'avais
complètement oublié
et maintenant c'est mais c'est devenu un
de mes meilleurs souvenirs
tu vois et bien entendu vous n'étiez pas
restez vous conseille alors n'auront
n'étions pas rester au conseil effet
c'est la nuit tu te rappelles même pas à
cette époque là c'était une nuit comme
une autre a bien changé depuis at-il dit
tu sais tu étais tu veux je le rappelle
que sont sûrement parce qu'il était
drôle noix de coco
nous autres encore dolent épaules les
émissions ne suffisait pas il fallait
nous aussi nous tenons
oui tout ce qu'il a dit au préfet ce que
tu voudrais quoi c'est peut-être
s'étaient tous et il a justement miettes
en battant le terrain mais moi ce bois
sais tu qui je suis non je suis le baron
le baron d'acapulco
j'ai couché avec ma femme
chez moi en bus divia toujours de paris
ça se passera pas comme ça jeter la
balle toutes sortes et mes enfants
sûreté
[Musique]
alors il m'a crié à travers la porte
ouais mon père il m'a dit tu imagines
avec nathalie duval a raccompagné chez
elles et tu vas rentrer de couches et
jared parler demain
il t'a paris furieux oh oui ça oui
contre toi je sais pas c'était contre
moi ça fait une bêtise je sais pas
probablement trois mois qu'il ait appris
appris quoi bon gignac t il je ne sais
pas monsieur antoine
pourquoi devons nous pas d'idées avec
les autres les autres vous êtes les
seuls qui est dit n'est ni si on peut
appeler ça finira par vous avouerez
c'est pas de ma faute
voyez monsieur calvi les messieurs
salvador sont partis sans dîner oui vous
savez pas pourquoi mais non messieurs
mais où l'art verrier entendu dire si à
quoi on avait un qui disait qu'elle a
fait hier un homme qui disait que
l'histoire qui a dit qu'à la fin c'est
monsieur salvatore c'était lui qui avait
vainement plus embêté d'ailleurs
forcément ça veut dire et ce soir il va
lui falloir chasser d'un travers les
rues mais oui madame avait dans sa
chambre avec les autres mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font on y écrit tous non c'est
seulement monsieur madame dos rond on
que ce qui là encore a créé un studio
mais non vous n'avez pas compris c'est
un monsieur jospin qui criaient c'était
monsieur monsieur encore qu'est ce
qu'ils disaient et crier trop fort j'ai
pas compris et madame je serai et bien
j'ai vaguement entendu qu'elle disait à
monsieur il faut chasser ses deux filles
j'ai même cru un moment qu'il s'agissait
de cuisinière mais c'est pas possible
puisqu'ils ont patiné mais madame que
fait madame ben je crois qu'elle pleure
qu'est ce que vous dites c'est pas
possible que ça m'a étonné d'autant que
vous mais je suis presque sûr on l'avait
entendu pleurer ce qui doit être
contente qui la déteste j'veux bien
entendu aussi autre chose mais je ne
sais pas si je peux dire à monsieur
antoine pourquoi pas enfin c'est
tellement extraordinaire
raison de plus c'est madame qui l'a dit
juste avant de pleurer et bien et bien à
vous le dirais pas que voulait répéter
après tout ça me regarde pas mais non je
dirai rien à faire non plus moselle non
plus eh bien madame a dit soyez
tranquilles je m'en vais tout de suite
elle s'en va c'est tout ce que j'ai
entendu vous savez pas pourquoi mais là
je ne vous le dira 10dans chalon n'a pas
prononcé mon nom viendrait faire là
dedans on gèle on n'a pas parlé de moins
à ça ne sais pas peut-être je me serais
pas permis d'écouter et
elle s'en va pas pour toujours j'en suis
pas sûr mais j'ai l'impression qu'il va
peut-être faire un voyage au nom
pourquoi vous dites non je dis non à
cause de soyez tranquille c'est le parti
en voyage à lloret pandy soyez
tranquilles ah oui ça c'est vrai
d'ailleurs pourquoi senti tranquille
ciel non non vous aurez malentendu
langel set repartait vraiment vous
n'avez pas demandé de faire c'est mal
maintenant peut-être de plus pleurer
pour sa honda qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire ses invités qui s'en vont
ce mystère ce qui n'est qu'on nous fait
faire ses cris ses larmes et nathan ce
départ c'est le pont naturel poursuivra
cache-misère tokyo nous expliquer ce qui
se passe là oh oh là là quoi prédit je
connais cette odeur aussi la wii a est
mon nouveau parfum d'un cadeau de ton
père à wignehies d'arabie oui j'ai même
été assez toujours mieux tous et au
revêtement il est quand même penser à
faire de petits cadeaux spas et batlam
et la tête tout de suite pourquoi je te
fais craquer ce qui se passe là haut
vous pouvez disposer en veulent
rien ça va comment ça bah oui et après
tu crois j'ai rien d'ailleurs pourtant
bon du tout un simple malentendu
mais vous vous avez des idées oui ici
oui oui oui et pourquoi tu demandes ce à
penser qu'il serait peut-être un petit
quelque chose mais c'est vrai que bien
qu'on ait faim toi je crève ou les
écouter à tacoma tabarez a fait 8 ans
moi j'ai pas le temps d'attendre qu'on
surmonte ben oui alors bon et puisque ça
va ça va c'est entendu mais vaut
peut-être mieux quand même que leurs
banques
pourquoi dites vous ça angèle on vous
demande pas votre avis d'après ce que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure j'ai plutôt
l'impression de vous l'énervé m'écouter
au compte maintenant il ya pas besoin
d'écouter pour entendre mais où ça je
comprends vraiment pas pourquoi tu es tu
va énervé papa dans l'état où il est je
ne joue pas dans le calme à l'hôtel à
10,7 à enlever ça va plus non vous
devriez remonter oui oh ça sera pas pire
en tout cas
irex fait l'armoire du parquet allait
renverser la mort on dirait que c'est
idiot
tant pis je m'endormis en tout cas tu es
tranquille maintenant il s'agit pas de
toi joseph je leur ai dit à mon jeu vous
cherchez voulez vous préparer ma malle
sur la dronne et celle que vous voudrez
vous mettrez un pelage les robes les
clous simple puis mon nécessaire non non
non pas les bijoux
merci souvenez vous dire a demandé rien
je vous en prie n'imposait pas crise on
a poussé on serait trop difficile de
répondre
pourtant mr ne me donnait pas selon
l'aïe perrin qui ne va guère et du reste
vous vous en êtes jamais servi avec
beaucoup de conviction c'est à dire j'ai
été parfois rudes un sévère avec vous
mais c'était pour votre bien puis-je me
croyez le droit j'espère vous ne
regardez pas rancune il n'est pas idiot
tout de même seulement vous demander de
ne pas garder deux mois un trop mauvais
souvenir ce ridicule
des on dit au revoir pendant que vous
pouvez encore être gentil non j'irai à
mon père je vais lui dire je lui dirai
qua non c'est bête mais c'est surtout à
cause de vous qu'il faut que je vois mal
à cause de moi mais c'est trop bas je
sans toi il faudrait que très gentil
avec la petite nathalie ya ne sera pas
défendre quoique vous en pensiez il aura
bien besoin de vous madame vous de nous
embrasser pas non
je vous remercie d'avoir ton site tu vas
là tu pas quel plaisir de monter dessus
et enfin nous n'avons plus rien à nous
dire à me dire tu vas encore rien dit a
fait pleurer
qu'est ce que tu attends donc j'espère
mais j'espère des explications
figure-toi droite ou même encore la
toile oui
et j'aimerais bien savoir ce qui se
passe en monsieur veut savoir ce qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire de mains
de carole 120 d'abord vaslui elles sont
a volontairement m'évoque torrent de
condé et ont depuis été nourris avec
carole tapas et senio répété qu'il
fallait les mais il a respecté et que
c'était ta femme qu'il fallait que
qu'elle allait remplacer la mairie
cetera et cetera
certes il a été insulté quand je mets
pas assez la troupe bizarre qu'elle s'en
aille aujourd'hui 50 disent pourquoi et
qu'on espère je trouvais ça naturel ah
oui sauf que tu lui parles pourra-t-on
10 a vraiment au sol torontois bien
entendu quand tu es en colère que cette
vitrine est ce que tu fais tu de
nanterre doit être réconciliée avec elle
dans 5 minutes dans l'eau retrouvée
noyau de laisser commencer à faire ce
matin qu'elle veut regarder tous les
deux pour 27 mois quatorze américains
elle m a dit toi tu cries et insulte ou
langue tu parce que donner des gifles à
lyon mais le jeu irlandais mon coeur
derrière votre père et son ami vous mais
vous c'est pas mal hein mais faut pas
prendre mon père au sérieux alors écrit
beaucoup mais c'est un homme juste et un
brave homme dit reconnaître à cet homme
erreur et tout s'arrangera très bien
mais fait l'auteur explique plus tard
bon alors fita noir mais la loi antoine
et bogota
les aztèques ambitieux de la part du bon
bref je te préviens talent il aura beau
à tampa la télé oui ou non
bonjour à mort à quatre pattes il
affiche pour que j'ai dit c'est new york
alors pour me donc vous avez été très
gentil mais partait ma plante vous
voulez pas de châssis j'attends le
conseille pas
une aubade à bomber astuces et antoine
très bien le bonsoir et les bossus
monsieur je m'en vais à bientôt carroll
a bientôt carole je vois que tout est
arrangé
on va s'arranger parce qu'il a bientôt
des côtes ils disent ils disent bien os
x et magnéto
ah oui et là il est bon d'aller
rejoindre fernando doit être d'un petit
salon est bon mais je fais partie mais
je préfère j'espère pour faire un allié
nous non mais je ne crois pas trop
compliqué pour lui ont pas du notw
d'ailleurs s'il comprenait par hasard
c'était la même chose tu penses tout de
même pas que je vais lui demander son
avis à lui donc je sais pourquoi m'as-tu
menti bon on pourrait peut-être ce soir
ce sera sans doute assez longs mois
répond je ne t'ai pas menti quand tu te
déshabilles d'honnêtes commerçants ont
fondu de 17 ans je suis fille données de
commerçants et 17 au jeudi au public la
suit aussi l exacte sans doute en partie
il tente dit a recueilli malheureusement
c'était un vieil ont déjà tant non non
en fait il a essayé c'est pour ça que je
suis parti a bien fallu rester chez lui
six mois je crois qu'il pensait à rien
seul mot un soir des rentrées par erreur
dans la salle de bal des gens sont là tu
fermes et porte à porte
et puis qu'est ce que ça peut te faire
réprimer leur nombre est un petit bateau
de la palestine elle
j'attends alors j'ai été séduite
comme on dit lâchement abandonnés comme
on dit ici
mais d'ailleurs celui-là tu peux pas te
plaindre c'est celui là que tu avais
raconté je me racontais que celui là les
autres pas intéressant même pas pour moi
d'aller beaucoup donc ça mon nom sur toi
je peux les compter enfin ça m'amuserait
pas il toi non plus tu vas chanter
chanter dans des beuglants avec ma voix
malheureusement j'avais aussi des gens
ne voient pas pourquoi pourquoi l'entrée
en france figure toi qui tend ce petit
pays à ces messieurs merritt oublier la
chanter qu'à acapulco niche antique
acapulco il ya quatre coups je les
chante et qu'elle elle de ragots
pourquoi pas fatine noix de coco c'est
une expression que j'employais que
quelle expression je me moquais de leurs
boniments à la noix de copier oui bah et
jette pas encore distingué quand tu
rentres en france comme mon contrat
était terminé parce que j'avais un
contrat de deux ans n'a pas pu t'en
rendes cool parce que t'es pas resté
assez longtemps mais la page
j'étais célèbre ensemble de remettre à
pierre monteux tradition afin de tenter
de continuer sa carrière artistique en
france ont jusqu'à faire j'ai offert une
maison de made in en juge par les
chapeaux du portable est jolie je n'ai
pas mal à faire faillite naturellement
au contraire au contraire j'étais
raconté qu'il y a trois ou quatre ans
j'avais fait un véritable oui c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai mais c'est pas tout
à fait faux non plus j'ai hérité de noix
de coco l'argent qu'elle avait gagné la
donne donné pour commencer une autre vie
c'est ce qui explique les trois ans que
j'ai passé dans votre ville
oizo exemple est enfin tu sait mieux que
personne la messe deux fois par semaine
nous voir la gueule que je mène
fait je l'avais pourtant payé le droit
d'être comme ça oubliez pas beaucoup de
femmes qui auraient donné trois zones
leur belle vie comme moi pour essayer de
recommencer
tout ça pour épouser le baroud à kaboul
enfin vous possédez gourmands oui et non
au fait c'est foutu c'est foutu mais la
virtu paix par l'acquisition
je suis le mari de noir et portant pas
tout le temps la même chose ça t'énerve
une femme qui consacre sa première venue
en ont peu dit il ça c'était des gens
très bien
non non non pas comment ma tous ne sont
pas par moi à moi je n'étais pas très
bien et ça c'est pas moi je le premier
soir un marchand de chaussures je savais
pas été marquée ce que j'avais n'est pas
tant que tu me le dire mais tu étais
très bien c'est pas des plus sublimes ça
me souvenir que tu étais très les
entrées de commandes de camions et
engins pour acapulco très drôle jamais
été autant jamais je ne pourrais te
pardonner d'avoir couché avec ce type
quel type mois le titre
l'incident qui n'a fait pour son plaisir
pas du tout
alors ce sera pire mais je ne les flics
parce que ça m'amusait battu wassalam
nerfs elle amusée d'ailleurs un type
comme toi est-ce que ça compte comme ans
dans la vie d'une femme de me dire je t
en imbécile pour souviens très bien et
prétentieux non monsieur lavaud somme
c'est toi surtout que tu es jaloux
ouais on n'est pas jalouse en appétit
rien donné que tu es tu es idiot ce lien
c'est terrible cette chaloupe du crétin
qu'on a été enfin quand tu peux tout de
même pas envoyer tes témoin on est très
spirituel steinway ou tu estimes que
j'aurais dû dire que j'avais chanté
acapulco
oui tiens le talent la ville aurait dû
épouser ne sais pas bah alors nos bottes
plates et tu le sais où tu as épousé
japd pas maman faire le rigolo j'essaie
d'expliquer les choses que tu n'as qu'à
imaginer qu'elle a été plusieurs fois
mariées avant de te connaître tente une
avec toi le as tu te serves as tu
t'intéresses dick tracy quand on se
marie on y va on sera mal et où en est
la première femme à aurora divorce pour
la rue c'est presque ce qui t'arrive la
seule différence dans ton cas c'est que
c'est pas si officiel on a dû passer
aussi fiable en effet grand d'ailleurs
tu dis tu veux qu'elle t'a menti elle a
pas menti
la oublié quelque chose tu es contente
de la façon dont il défend ensuite de
lemos croyait bien qu'un jour est
tellement devenu par tom fait que tout
s'arrange si les idiots ont du coeur
très bien connu pour ses fondements
parce que j'ai du coeur parce que je
vous aime bien carole pleurait trop de
remords d'armor je pensais bien ne pas
être oubliée peut le dire je croyais
pouvoir et considériez avant tout est
arrivé par ma faute
mouassa salvador vous avez jamais vus
carroll qui n'était jamais vu c'est un
truc là pour réprouver l'avait retenu la
régie me fait que les femmes ne sont pas
honnêtes elles ont toutes un quelque
part dans leur vie mme m'a énervé et
tout ça est arrivé parce qu'il est
énervé
ouais t'as voulu prouver qu'ils avaient
des femmes vraiment honnête des femmes
sur lesquelles les meilleurs trucs ne
prendrai pas les goûts
bon c'est bien gentil de ta part et même
pas voulu qu'il essaye avec fernande bon
je croyais à votre vertu
vous m'excuserez alors
faudrait pas qu'un brave garçon soit
puni d'être aussi bête ça serait trop
pénible penser que tout ça a plu à vue à
cause de moi mais faire un effort un
loup
mais voulait bien pardon
[Applaudissements]
carole
le poser une question idiote parce que
tu m'aimes bien sûr je t'aime bien
malgré tout sauf ridicule que tu m'as
donné mais tu crois passionnant peu pour
moi aussi tirer dit que si nous pouvions
nous débrouiller façon ou d'une autre
statue contente
jacques lapointe série le mans sera
difficile mais tout le monde ça contre
nous pour les autres qui m'inquiète
kiala et nous toi mais comment veux tu
que tu me respectes après ce que tu m'as
fait et comment pourrais je n'ai pas
respecté si tu me garde mais toi quoi
moi tu me respectes bien sûr bien sûr
évidemment je te respecte et je pense
que c'est impossible
qu'est-ce que tu apprécies tu veux
m'embrasser des chiens bat alors son
ancien chef
oui comme ça alors semi ce baiser c'est
à noix de coco qui demande le pendu tous
les biens sentis y avait quelque chose
de plus ben brik dans ta voix 2 lubrique
oui parfaitement
mais tu vas pas recommencer à jouer
blessé non
12 à se faire longue histoire mais c'est
sûrement très intéressant elle disait
car en la vertu elle exagère ban avait
raison pour rejeter totalement honnête
la moitié de son résultat savais pas que
c'était trop moi je voyais vraiment
ressembler à ma mère possible en tout
cas maintenant c'est inutile je ne crois
pas non mais comprend mois à partir de
10h du sort tu devenais vrai nom est
possible je t'assure à croire que tu
avais un amant plus faire un geste
je m'abandonne n'est pas assez voilà tu
te faire chambre à part
ridicule tu croire ridicule comme si des
dalles mercredi chez fernand des idiots
vidéo mon but était tout seul
ma grande chambre alors qu'est ce qui va
changer tout ça je te prie de le croire
mais qui n'a pas peur de tous ces
changements
au contraire j'ai pourtant pas oublié de
te dire que noix de coco était morte
infinie terminé c'était caroline renard
que tu avais posé je ne compte pas du
tout sur ta mémoire je compte sur ta
bonne volonté je resterai ta femme
plus que jamais c'est moi j'avais deux
femmes je n'aurai plus qu'une celle que
j'avais le jour mais je regarderai la
lune
comme çà comme çà l'incident le petit
drame d'aujourd'hui aura presque était
utile il faut pas que ce qui nous arrive
prennent des allures d'une captation des
spams évidemment très embêtant ce qui
nous arrive ça vaut tout de même mieux
que se casser une jambe
c'est d'ailleurs malheureusement ça
n'empêche pas alors puisque puisqu'on
peut rien faire d'autre
on essayait d'en rire tu pourras oui
c'est tu m'aimes tu pourras rire avec
les autres est plus fort que faux pas il
faut pas leur permettre de nous abîmer
acapulco au moment où ils s'amuseront le
plus dans 4 ap les promenades à dos de
mulet clair de lune banal
il y avait tout de même les mulets et
puis ça avait beau ne pas en avoir l'air
c'était tout de même
acapulco ma pauvre et a dit embêté coups
bas ici je suis mort une femme comme toi
après l'eldorado
toutes ces confitures que je te prête à
un peu de champagne bar boire un verre
de champagne avec moyenne
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu es ma gueule
champagne c'est ce qu'ils doivent on
était obligé au revoir c'est dans le
contrat mais dès qu'on me regardez pas
moi je vis de ma coupe sous la table à
baltimore avait un petit quelque chose
non voici obligés femme à se voiler
qu'est ce que tu vas faire sonner au
fait tu veux pas déranger angel à 10
heures du soir pour préparer assoupi non
j'ai alors pour toi pour maintenant et
je veux croire qu'on rangeait
non-réponse apport de nauzan bêtement
parce que tu te rends compte de ce qui
se passe
non tu avais raison tout à l'heure quand
nous pourrons peut-être nous arranger
des autres mais de nous
pourquoi si on est déjà à m'offrir du
champagne
tu veux m'embrasser du m'offre du
champagne alors c'est mal fait pas
l'innocence une méprise je te mets
précis naturel d'ailleurs tu pardonnes
métaux n'oublie rien
c'est toi qui peux pas si c'est ça ton
pardon moi je ne veux pas de bandol suis
pas une fille tu comprends je suis marié
mois marié tiens moi tu te dis ça alors
on a surtout vu si le choix je voudrais
pas plus avant tout une tente en pas
pourquoi pas tes yeux au sol une brique
domino ni respect ni tendresse encore le
reste les affrètements non-respect moi
j'ai besoin de ton respect de la fin des
vols de moins exigeante avec certains
marchands de chaussures de ma
connaissance fine à dire une lâcheté
il est vrai qu'il était jeune beau à la
machette insultes avec mon désir si j'en
juge par cette pluie d'acapulco avec lui
aurait pas eu souvent la migraine gtgc
bien secrétaires et les autres cocu
peuvent pas sauver autant que moi
peuvent pas s'imaginer ce qui s'est
passé entre leurs femmes et les autres
moi j'essaye j'étais là
je me rappelle thomas péter dans ses
bras je me rappelle exactement en et
skybox à l'est rien faire oui et moi
pauvre idiot on apprenait via la musique
en expliquer cet ex amie pour te faire
plaisir pour elle sans doute que je
continue mes gosses qu'a presque dû lui
a appris jamais je te faire de dhr est
ce que tu viens taper pour toi je n'ai
rien fait de mal tu déjà les femmes en
admettant que la dezir quoi plus naturel
alors fais ton avis acapulco tu chantais
à qui voulait l'entendre chanter c'est
ben oui tu chantais g cham et chaud si
ça venait d'entamer une robe jaune
dedans noir j'aime chanter trois
chansons du tout les mêmes et jamais ses
nerfs tu ne chantait pas facile mais
c'était partie remise et alors ils
s'offrent pour être moins pu niveau
quand on a passé sa jeunesse à brailler
michaud m oui je chante tu prends la
chose gaiement je la prends comme il
plaît c'est mon honneur oui ou non
d'ailleurs pour ce qu'il en reste
si j'ai bien compris cette chanson est
tout un programme on commence on ne peut
pas passer des femmes
ça veut dire que tu gardes la tienne
telle qu'elle est ne s'est pas tu ne
sais pas vraiment trop beagle
c'est la seule chose qui me frappe dans
son cas pudibonderie ridicule qu'est ce
qui a bien pu lui demander ses
grossièretés m'étonne de votre part et
non quand saura-t-elle ne s'en va pas
elle s'en va pas si si si rassurez vous
monsieur les contraintes et les mâles
gens ne provient pas mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça j'espère que vous aurez
le tact de ne pas emporter nos bijoux de
famille je savais que ce serait votre
première pensée j'ai bien recommander
angèle de vous en faire un pas que je
tape mon mot à dire nature milan perd tu
n'as rien à dire t'as faiblesses et on
manque de discernement tu te placer dans
une situation grotesque
laisse moi les autres essayaient de
temps sorti j'en sortirai cheveux coupés
vous êtes extraordinaire ton ça non mais
tu n'es pas seule en cause
ce département une affaire votre madame
et toi entre qui et qui alors et tu as
un fils tu ne peux pas l'obliger à
rencontrer tous les jours cette
fourrière noorda raison tu ne comprends
pas moi je suis là pour te faire
comprendre je comprends très bien
je suis là pour t'expliquer ton voire je
replace sa mère malheureux je ne te
laisserai pas donné le foyer de cette
femme assez petit body ce petit le
passager pacifique vignes patrie ya moi
ok ça peut le faire toi tu me demandes
et du là toi ton foyer jean ray ozzie
pour bell mais cette personne qui
chantait sur l'état voilà jamais chanté
sur l'étape 112 que fernando rey fait à
ma place
oh c'est pas la peine de jouer les
femmes du monde avec new non je n'y
songe pas garder votre air distinguer
pour sortir dans la rue vous en aurez
besoin
qu'est ce que tu espères irak pardon
mais vous ne comprenez pas que tout ceci
est ici dès demain vous montrera du
doigt et on vous épargnera pas les
avanies bon ici tu la gardes ce sera la
même chose pour toi ben tant pis si
ferrari top et ça sera dans tous
commerces je ne crois pas le coût humain
c'est toujours du cousu main
ils vendront sur mes chaussures je crois
on va tant pis mais il réfléchit papa tu
vas faire une grande bêtise n'a pas
jamais gratuite en tout cas on verra
plus jamais là si monsieur ne l'espère
pas il faut choisir entre ta fille et
cette fille
d'après ce moment là surtout tu n'as pas
le droit n'est pas si intransigeante
c'est trop facile pour toi ça guerre
révèle plus noir tandis que moi tu
marques d'entrée sont horribles tuéni
mais on peut pourtant faire un drame
toute cette histoire
après tout de même que moi ah non tu ne
t'en tireras barre de l'esprit mais tu
peux même temps de réfléchir réfléchit
un peu toi même on ne se remet pas 47
ans devant inzaghi de les choses
examiner les choses toi oui mais tu déjà
vu le bonhomme dans ma petite hélice y
finir ma vie avec celle là plaisait aux
autorités à ne pas pouvoir disposer de
ma vie et qui n'est pas évidemment très
regrettable de lieux ça vous plaise pas
dire aux uns ni aux autres alors été
tellement sûr que ça vous regarde quoi
votre à mon pote ne vont pas le reste de
ma vie bien à lorient ne s'arrangera
peut-être que carole pas envie de rester
c'est à faire entrer deux mois vous
séparer à père de ses enfants
il pourrait vous en coûter cher prenez
garde je suis trop faible pour avoir
peur vous avez l'intention de rester
devant demain vous pouvez admettre
qu'ils sacrifient tout pour vous je vous
le dirai demain vous compter beaucoup
sur cette nuit ce qu'elle est amusant je
veux partir je pars mais mon pauvre papa
comme tu vas être ridicule le mmm
important grand crime
heureusement tu auras toujours pour tous
à l'histoire dès mercredi
mercredi je n'ai pas besoin de ça serait
beau mais quoi mais quelle histoire de
mer
quand on sort avec qui tu passais le
mercredi qui aura tout de même l'air un
peu vécu par city le mercredi mais avec
mama zelko nettement tattoo c'est une de
vos amis non pas du tout mais si elle
avait dix ans de plus ça aurait pu être
une démo mais aussi c'est gentil mais
pourquoi je sais où le passé ce mercredi
tu avais bien venir lui dire sa
confiance en vous et moi qui vous croyez
monnaie mais c'est bien pour ça depuis
des années qu on ne pouvait pas de
jaloux d'une femme pareille jeunesse
la raison n'est même pas ce n'est pas
joli du tout et tout en elle et surtout
d'une betis exactement comme si tu me
disais que je ne peux pas mal avec
plaisir et du coup je touche la balle
de sandwichs à leur bien-être de bière
ou aux veaux le mien s'il vous plaît là
pas devant mais pourquoi dites vous ça
en jette vous savez très bien qu'il
reste du vous aviez oublié et après je
pourrais aller me coucher
le monsieur s'est kabylie ne peux pas
dormir je lui fasse avant beaucoup à
l'excès parce qu'on crie qu'on claque
les portes dites lui que maintenant elle
a peu dormi au savon fini parce que nous
avons vraiment oui c'est décidé tu vas
faire ce scandale dans l'epr rien de ta
lettre à même le chagrin des enfants
c'est parce qu'on pensera antoine
châtain joseph et est avec nous tu es
avec eux oui toujours par monde sa la
maison
carole lui fait enfin pour carole et
merci mais je ne fais que c'était votre
sac et celui-ci se trouvait complètement
il n'est pas question de sa générosité
du différentes je sais tout je sais
aussi que c'est un coupable et je me
tairai que lorsque j'aurai réparer tu
aurais pas vrai tout est je viens genii
on sait déjà tout ce qui s'est passé ici
par le reptile
oui c'est par monsieur colleville en
effet monsieur madame brand est bas plus
catalogué ni s'ils ont le même défendu
de me revoir aux notes et on n'a pas
voulu me dire pourquoi mais on accusait
carroll ont laissé entendre que c'était
pas une année de femmes
bonjour m hamel toiles et pinceaux
peintures à l'eau alors j'ai compris tu
as trouvé mais m antoine je suis recours
oui oui ça l'est de son moi mais carolla
jamais répondu jallet se voit le seul
coupable c'est un coup de folie qui m'a
plu qui peut pas la plus dure de ma
folie dit mais qu'est-ce qui aura cours
c'est peut-être un peu trop 10 mhz je
suis conscient qu'il travaille
oui tu vas peut-être trop tard tu crois
que je t'ai eu trop tard odense ailleurs
dépassé sa tasse ex alex ottawa et
carole sauter cette campagne dresser
l'un contre l'autre
oh oui j'aime ta femme papa
allons bon
femme au g8 est encore jeune j'ai le
temps que j'ai plus jamais ça y est tu
as détesté
mais c'est toi qui me pousse à tout le
temps vers elle va être ma photo pc
d'infos tel père tel fils il n'a pas
connu sa mère sont attendus surtout pas
une raison pour quoi que je lui ai dit
par les imaginer des choses
la chemise par exemple dont je parlais
elle n'a pas donné c'est moi qui les
volait apporter voilà aussi la cheville
si la réponse est lu freud his way est
innocente de tout jeter tout dit je le
sentais toi ça va tu auras tu peux faire
moi tout ce que tu voudras maintenant
quelle soirée
ça alors
oui qu'est ce que tu vas faire et je ne
sais pas
sortie monsieur alors voyons voulez vous
sortir bouchage et oui mais peut-être
mal compris mais j'ai très bien compris
au contraire c'est très simple
d'ailleurs vous vous dites pourquoi pas
moi pas tout à fait les je n'ai pas le
temps d'analyser vos sentiments voulez
vous sortir vous répéter tout dans la
même chose si vous n'avez pas l'air de
m'entendre pour faites bien attention
mais ce sera un scandale de plus j'en
suis alors voulez vous sortir non bah
alors vous l'aurais voulu
c'est comme ça que tu penses arranger
nos affaires nouvelles et a vu la gifler
j'ai vu est pire si je vais être obligé
de donner une autre gifle et toi aussi
excuse-moi vrai pourquoi je te plaît
pourquoi telle gifle est bon avait tu
vois bien n'a tort d'être aussi
catégorique je veux garder ta femme
c'est très touchant il faudrait encore
que depuis je pourrais très bien je ne
crois pas je ne sais pas comment tu as
reçu ça avec ton amour propre mais je ne
sais surtout pas comment tu pourras la
rangée avec ton intérêt 4 mais vous ne
vous rendez pas compte de ce qui vous
arrive
hier au cercle on n'a parlé que de vous
à ça en plus a bien ri la mort depuis tu
sais comme ils sont je crois que tu as
perdu ta place à la norme le conseil de
fabrique va te demander de choisir entre
elle et à des missions sur ses pas la
lettre aujourd'hui il me faut un autre
situation relève dans la première vous
serez plus reçu nulle part c'est pas
tellement grave c'est tout non on attend
quoi
il ya encore autre chose très embêtant
je sais je m'en souviens plus merci pour
toutes ces bonnes nouvelles n'oubliez
pas de fermer la porte en sortant bien
avisés de 10 ans brisé ses vêtements
rachetant prix et par ne nous le couplet
mélancolie comme tu voudras mais je te
plaît à dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'arrête de courir ok merci à toi or la
peine merci enchaîne rappelle antoine il
a dormi monsieur me demande si j'ai bien
dormi
oui c'est amusant ah oui c'est très
amusant je le dirai la cuisine et à fait
sûr qu elle trouvait ça très drôle et
aussi rabat en mieux enfin jusqu'à 6h du
matin nous avons entendu claquer
l'effort galoper dans les escaliers
hurler comme s'il y avait dû y avait le
faut et monsieur me demande si j'ai bien
dormi
alors que tu étais un peu bruyant apple
non monsieur qui disait qu'il avait fini
lui ont pas tout à fait fini ce que me
suis entraîné réveiller madame vous
parle je n'avais pas entendu je vous
demande si monsieur antoine est réveillé
je ne sais pas plus que vous ne savez
pas il a pris son petit déjeuner non au
lieu de dire non madame et à monsieur et
leur fils je ne sais pas le 10 heures à
les réveiller monsieur antoine et dites
lui de s'habiller voilà une
je vais [ __ ] à la porte n'aura pas
cette peine
toutes les deux ont quitté ton service
avant ce soir
pourquoi parce qu'elles savent ça et je
les entends déjà je lui dirais
franchement madame ce que je pense des
n'ont pas jusque là où je te prie de
croire qu'elle se confrontent les
tesselles sable pas beau présent béton
on peut bien nous envoyer un ananas et
rire avec cette attente mattel doit bien
y avoir une lettre à l'ananas ferai tout
ce que j'aime et couru les magasins de
mon quartier je n'ai pas pu trouver 2
il n'a pas pu trouver de noix de coco
moi si tu peux rien je sais ta nana là
parce que c'est ce qui semble plus tout
amusé ça pas le seul à avoir cette idée
qui ne seront pas besoin d'acheter de
décès pendant longtemps c'est signé w je
n'ai pas pu lui non plus mon pauvre
vieux ne sont pas finis tous y
trouveront autre chose il leur iden de
séparer remarque bien ils ont tort parce
qu'il nous rapproche gentil de les dire
mais tu le crois vraiment même si je
n'avais pas l'intention de garder les
meilleurs bijoux et puis il tout le
monde roule ou de choisir votre moi et
puis tout le reste je sais mais ta
situation l'argent qu'ils donnent tout
voudra tout sacrifié depuis je suis
tellement egoiste un vrai compagnon
loyal jusqu'au n'est même plus loin que
le bout puis loyal consanguinité sans
faire d'histoires royal comme comme si
c'était pas difficile est si peu de
chance c'est plus que tu dis là
j'invite très bien j'ai pas eu de chance
que tu me plaisent
autrement que comme compagnon
explique-t-on à 0,2 du savès qu'a failli
être notre nuit de la voix
heureusement que cet ivrogne en essayant
de rentrer dans notre chambre d'hôtel
mme à dégriser
ça lui plaisait tellement j'étais sur le
point d'abandonner alors il fallait pas
à ma patronne aussi après ma mort c'est
la cour 11 11 mois enfin tu t'étais
soudain endormi dans les bras de matt
bobo je me serais pas endormi en londres
a éveillé si tu préfères tu préfères wii
qui aurait plutôt été surpris
désagréablement ton plus plutôt oui mais
pas désagréable mais tu te souviens bien
acapulco très bien ces mêmes fins de
peine et b j'ai failli
abadie d'or mais j'étais vraiment venu
fava comme là bas j'ai manqué sam sont
les deux seules fois de ma vie mon jeu
parce qu'après j'ai mis bon ordre
tu tournes héros du conte à 10 heures du
soir mon jeu devenait impossible à cause
de l'idée de la chambre a pas arrosé
j'étais ta femme une femme que tu aimais
que je respecte et je pourrai pas en
même temps être être maîtresse déchets
pour une fois qu'on pouvait avoir les
deux en même temps
non je pouvais pas avoir de vie une une
très pur lots et aurait pu choisir
l'autre non ça c'était pas possible tu
m'as est placé trop tu m'admirer osseux
trobe mais tu sais des fois c'était
difficile pour la gt si gentil si
séduisant certains soirs je peux le dire
maintenant mais j'ai été héroïque il
entend demander portant sur 12 villes
étaient à mes frais terrorisme alors
c'était ça son secret c'est bien ça les
femmes et ne garde que les secrets qui
doit vous faire plaisir
une espèce de petit saute mais comprend
donc les bords les beaux hommes ont
besoin de deux bonnes femmes chacun
joliment celle du jour est celle de la
nuit celle du jour c'est la mère de leur
enfance et leur associé si leurs
complices et leurs compagnes c'est leur
meilleur ami mais l'autre ils sont bien
obligés d'aller la chercher à
l'extérieur c'est le ventadoux bon alors
là tu connais mon restant madame
robillard si les girondins une danseuse
du municipal je vais faire rire la
macreuse le père macreuse madame col v
[Rires]
pas besoin de te donner des idées mais
nous nous avions tout à la maison et je
découvrais le mercredi mais alors mais
aux fourrures heureusement que salvador
est venu dit
où sont les alcools ils sont aussi la
petite éclaircie y avait le plus raide
le mal tant mieux or du rhum
qu'est ce qui se passe du bois du mardi
heure du matin au lieu oui une question
n'était pas rasé non plus travail
devrait probablement plus jamais au 8a
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu dis d'ailleurs
présidé à côté dépassé par les
événements et bien moi aussi j'ai
dépassé par les évènements toi oui mon
vieux depuis quand ce matin c'est
rarement le cas avant les événements de
dépenses candidats on se remet pas c'est
tomber le garde ni à 8 jets dépendant
vie de la nuit n'en est pas un cash mais
comme rien de plus fort s'il vous plaît
les migrants c'est arrivé quelque chose
oui à toi ben oui moi oui babet toi là
tu parlais 96 des voix dans la boîte
d'un griot dray et quelque part
mais vous ne pouvez vraiment pas nous
ratons bruit surtout pas beau mais si je
voulais c'est au mexique 1-1 d'ailleurs
pendant que vous devriez bien dire un
mot à un jeune
or vu pascal morand la porte elle a dit
encore vous comment ça encore voter je
suis pas si c'est petit mais c'est très
tard ya répondu allez penser que vous
avez dit rien montré mais certainement
tir debout suis non non non c'est ta
fille puisqu'elle a fait enlever dessus
de t'embêter hype les affaires
personnelles mais le tout est petit
souci qu'est ce qu'elle a fait fausse
c'est dur de bien ça va te parler oui
avant que ta vie soit ma fille tout le
portrait de sa mère
on me dit penser un vélo tu dis c'est
sûr pourquoi youtube gaillard d une
chose pareille
et qui dit quoi avec qui ressemble t
elle à sa mère ne peux pas te dire tu
sais pas si mais c'est un nom trop
difficile je le connais ma wii s'est la
junior alsacien quoi libre club peut pas
retenir seulement la libye grant alors
ça c'est comique on nous rabâche dont
georges non je veux dire c'est révoltant
comment l'as tu sues urbain à cause de
ton histoire bien soit quelle histoire
j'en ai eu plusieurs alors commence à
plusieurs camps c'est l'histoire
d'antoine celle des carreaux de celle de
caroline bien entendu je vois pas
comment on va pourtant bien simple un
nom là sinon
7 puis nous sommes rentrés à 6h du matin
so lu ment exténué nous m'oriente fin en
plus comme taille foot et où les
enductions est de rester un peu nerveux
ça s'est alors jetée construit par la
suite nous sommes donc allés jusqu'à la
cuisine voir s'il restait pas un petit
quelque chose ou presque rien fille un
peu de vos justement alors nous le
mans-lyon bavardant tranquillement ça
tranquillement merci enfin bavardions
corps quand tout d'un coup quand tout
d'un coup faire tandis qu'à la place de
caroline elle se serait jamais su
prendre je la regarde et langis nantis
elle s'aperçoit que je m'en aperçois et
au dire de ne pas citer tant bagré
explications là pour justifier ce
qu'elle vient de dire les normes
tu peux pas suivre c'est donc
intéressant ça m'étonne de la part de
fernand alors vu la lettre s'enfoncer
alors subitement le téléphone sonne dans
sa chambre 7h du matin à la hâte de
venir
2ème ligne particulière alors le
décroche sa beauté des choses à sa femme
amy jamais mais jamais je réponds moi
depuis l'histoire de ta femme n'est pas
content
enfin le décroche et l'entente l'autre
me dire bonjour chérie c'est à dire ça à
toi
alors je réponds pas alors il continue
notre réveil pas mon chou et n'oublie
pas quatre heures chez moi c'était et
l'alsacien du bord quand tu dis oui oui
pas soupçonner que tu auras des ennuis
de son côté nick ne resterions si tard
chez toi alors qu'il téléphonait 1 comme
tous les matins avant d'aller à l'usiné
fernanda oui peut-être quelqu'un qui se
promènent numéro 31 ans nous vient te
préciser la plaie fermente
tapez 2 un peu de frais 10 morts
en tout cas ça me fait beaucoup de peine
merci méritait pas ça non il va divorcer
jamais de la vie j'aimerais que tu
penses à la tête du barça
quelque chose à dire c'est assez
difficile parce que je ne voudrais pas
être maladroit vient d'un autre côté
j'ai tellement mal à la tête mais je te
comprends dans les moteurs voilà bien
non monsieur non tu commences à te faire
vieux os
tu as trouvé la femme qui te fallait tu
veux garder carole madame banon
moi moi je te suis toni réseau seulement
revêtement préfet étant avertis ont été
empêchés de faire nombre
paris dans veux t'en empêcher ah oui tu
m'as compris je ne dirai rien nous
recommençons comme avant nous en faudra
qu'elle te laisse tranquille et samos
toujours que te laissera tranquille là
pour faire de la poussière quelques
bêtises aux halles pour apprendre à
faire du ranquet heureusement pour moi
d'ailleurs
l'alsacien c'est un [ __ ] toi tu es un
brave type tous les idiots ou du coeur
c'est toi qui me l'a dit dans sa chambre
les gens paient oui les sorties du mois
il ya déjà une heure qu il est sorti il
avait besoin de prendre l'air ça ne
t'inquiète pas pas du tout oui oui j'ai
moi j'avais oublié cette nuit pendant
que tu démolissait le secrétaire antoine
m'avait donné ce rendez vous et pourquoi
qu'on est rendu obligatoire avant il
avait des choses importantes à savoir ce
que c'est j'y vais et ensemble à sa mère
phénomène était nerveux et peut pas me
ressemble et aboisso tellement plus
simple alors cette histoire le
subconscient se trouve pour tous même
pas formidable il quitte volts et
chemise et qui disent après que c'est
parce que je l'aï trop tard si tu passes
plus grave que c'est rien de plus grave
que le freudisme mieux le voir avec une
bonne grosse commande à soigner ou
plutôt ton fils est un petit truc très
sensible très tendre un il faudrait être
calme avec lui très doux il faudra
essayer de comprendre comprendre quoi
qu'est ce que tu veux que je comprenne
dans j'aime ta femme papa mais comprends
moi j'espère qu'on n'a pas eu peur de
quoi
j'y perds tu vois tu vois de même pas
qu'ils pensent à ce taux est non alors
alors alors j'avais dit que mais tu ne
l'écouté pas fière parce que tu était
furieux tu ne l'entendait pas à répéter
je ne finirais je finirai le pour lui
une punition c'est une reprise l'air
buté que tu peux avoir quelquefois ces
terres qui leur fait croire que tu es un
peu fou enfin c'est ton fils ne
l'oublient pas en jeu ne l'oublient pas
bon l'amour qu'il a pour moi nous nous
le considérer comme de l'enfantillage
mais pour lui c'est un crime c'est vrai
c'est pas ça je lui pardonne loulou il
faut qu'il faut que nous lui parlions
toi et moi toi surtout il faut il faut
près lui expliquer que ce n'est pas
grave qu'il s'est trompé qu'il faut lui
faire admettre qu'il n'est qu'un enfant
ce qui sera plus des visées rien je fais
aussi
non mais non mais je suis bien à bec de
m'énerver comme ça que je connais marc
antoine il n'ya jamais pensé d'abord
d'abord c'est mon fils comme didier
alors il me ressemble tout de même à
apple plus tu sors
il a l'air sérieux et profond comme ça
mais tout ça c'est très superficielle
crois moi je t'ai jamais raconté son
histoire avec mon frère albert était
encore un équivalent qui va les embêter
alberte quel sujet aulas au sujet de mon
affaire d'acapulco
oui toujours est il qu antoine détester
ce notre l'albert il est vrai qu albert
l'aimé pas trop non plus il y donnait
plus de paires de gifles que de pièces
de 5 francs et un jour c'était pendant
les vacances
albert et tout épaté de voir antoine
entrer dans sa salle de bain alors le
gosse leurs gardes se raser se laver les
dents pendant son baby il était aux
petits soins
son oncle et bien sûr maintenant et ça
va tu deviens maintenant je peux qui
vous met sa durée comme ça pendant dix
jours
or albert qui n'est pas bête que massa
trouvé bizarre que le monde soit tous
les jours à la salle de bain alors nous
demandons au petit jules michelet
d'espionner antoine pour savoir ce
qu'ils appuieraient dans la salle de 25
nous l'avons su il avait pisser dans
l'eau dentifrice ailleurs d'ailleurs
beaucoup le petit jules plisson la part
des deux premiers jours il a voulu
d'abord assisté lui aussi à la toilette
de l'europe ne perds et tu voudrais qu
un garçon qui a fait ça se suicident
nommé la grande qu il a grandi où il a
grandi si j'en juge par sa
correspondance et d'un petit homme
antoine mekouar le faust par l'abbé par
les villes de france mais pas du tout et
heureusement si ça vaut mieux merci car
le loup ou qu'on avait encore l'hyper
très mauvaise pioche agit bien je peux
le dire de voir le loufoque et du court
à toit en prends toi tu vas comprendre
ça par exemple alors lapin je vais
t'expliquer québécoise au bac il est
trempé
je suis au pays noir des serviettes de
l'autre colonne les décideurs à
l'intérêt sans preuve
c'est tombé à l'autre mais comment tu
fais ton corps tu veux tu peux pas
regarder youtube et les pieds non tu as
fait un faux pas ta glissé qu'est ce que
tu écris tu as tout de même pas pousser
alors hop
tu vas pas me dire que tu que tu voulais
tuer d'y répondre cacherai pas qu'il
voulait tuer et tu oses dire ça mais
témoignant que gdf ne pas y perdre mon
fiston de savoir ça s'est occupée de mes
petites affaires je m'énervais avec
derrière et monsieur préciser un peu mes
tantes sur ton lit parce que tu
[Applaudissements]
la tuer after peace mais justement
c'était l'une des raisons est bien viens
pas me dire qu'est ce que tu voulais
plus un constat moi j'ai le droit d'être
bête mais au point de vue la recette
mais pour quelqu'un est évident pour moi
c'est trop
vraiment tu trouveras l'hérault et où je
tournais après la juriste a même fait
mêle toi qui te regardent fais tes
bêtises si tu me laisses moi m'occuper
des solutions fredericton ben seddik je
te sais vers vous
oui c'est vrai pour palau belle et j'ai
pensé que mon argent de poche
mon fils mon fils c'est chic elle comme
un petit pauvre colonna
je vois qu'ils tentent donc les vestons
sur la berge après avoir mis ma lettre à
la poste
parce que tu vas être bête est ce que tu
me bassine petit baiser qui vous laisse
tuer commenté vu que toi qui te fait ni
par son petit ami grain pas soigné avec
la passion qui m'habite se calme pas
d'excusés maintenant monsieur pascal
jarry m'excuser mais plus bas je vais
essayer d'expliquer quelque chose de
très difficile à faire tous les deux ans
il va falloir que nous en parlions oui
on va essayer d'avoir du tact
dulayme à ce point oui c'est bizarre
qu'est ce qui te plaît tellement j'ai
des photos
bon bah oui mais où elle est tellement
fine tellement mystérieux race à tenir
je m'énerve pas si je m'énervais
pourquoi mais pourquoi tu pas mieux
nathalie moi ça discute pas mais tant
pis malgré très gentil nathalie ralenti
mais c'est pas pareil j'ai compris tu
appris qu au tout de suite dès le
premier jour quand tu nous a annoncé que
vous étiez fiancée robin la bonne heure
alors elle va parler comme une femme qui
se bat par à avoir un fils de 19 ans la
voyez que ces cieux ils sont merveilleux
ses yeux mais si son verbe et le cas
bien sûr tu crées de mal parce qu'elle
te regarde
mais moi dont elle ne s'occupait pas si
bien que ça c'est comme ça bouche en
bouche à bouche sur wii ça bouge surtout
d'ailleurs elle sait très bien ce
qu'elle fait remettant pas de rouge à
lèvres parce que on se demande tout de
suite et stella d'extraordinaire et les
convaincre c'est ça bouge justement
justement et puis je te dit rien de ses
oreilles ça tombe bien parce que tu as
oublié un peu trop que tu parles à son
mari on waro tu parles à son mari dont
10 hors oft a pas besoin d'être jaloux
de moi je suis jaloux de toi maintenant
au genre sérielle dit t'as pas besoin de
l'être
la cuvée der goot chanel cette année
mais je déteste ou si aulas auquel
générant ouija des tests est ce qui
m'empêche de l'aïr sais quel thème on a
perçu 300 fois
ça n'a pas sa part décourager nos bons
quand même dire que j'ai été assez
infects dans tout ça mais j'ai une
excuse
je crois sincèrement pas de personne
n'est jamais souffert autant que je
souffre en ce moment au mieux s'ouvrir
que ce emmerder ton père qui t'a dit
comme antoine vous venez sur le monde
prendre votre samba sur petit avc laisse
éleveuse rockhill c'est lui qui a raison
c'est à moi de partir entre et nathalie
mais qu'est ce que la tamise à faire là
dedans alors c'est vrai vous suivre
c'est une pratique mois jamais jamais
jamais jamais été question de ça tu m'a
pas dit je voulais te tuer tottenham est
question ça c'est bien ça ou je te
demande il voudra avec toi la voilà la
femme qui est folle de toujours disent
même que tu m'a répondu que je ne
pourrais pas ce que savait nager
abate moi c'était pour blaguer oui pour
blaguer oui pour blaguer la virée comme
une fontaine
alors qu'est ce que tu en penses
rien du tout bon eh bien moi je pourrais
pas supporter ça plus longtemps je m'en
vais encore non non non mais maintenant
je peux te dire maintenant ou tout
mauvais je t'aime beaucoup je te trouve
charmant je trouve un vieux coach
allemand je m'amusais avec toi j'étais
contente
vraiment oui je me dis à eric tu et à
toi comme vêtement j'aimais bien ta
façon mais mais sans en avoir l'air non
je veux qu'on te deux parties doivent
des bêtises à imbaba été témoin qui
partait ça serait la même chose non non
je viens ce qui est important c'est que
j'ai pu l'occasion de vous voir alors
s'il partait pour londres par exemple tu
penses dans quinze jours il aurait un
accident sur la tamise moi je le connais
ce petit là il va s'ouvrir c'est entendu
il va souffrir énormément mais que tu me
dis ça comme si ça devait me faire
plaisir
pas du tout il va souffrir il sait déjà
qu'on ne tombera pas toujours un
c'est vrai en toi parce que c'est vrai
je vais souffrir forcément
parce que la vie quand même elle est
longue
oh oui ce qu'elle est longue bon je
partirai pour lendemain tamise entendu
fiston
ne vous inquiétez pas
[Applaudissements]
faut pas dormir tu sais moi j'avais
oublié ta peau de tout ce que tu m'as
dit je ne t'ai rien n'est pas comment
rama propos d'antoine non non écoute
joseph tu prends ton de cacher ça tape
sur la tête
toi moi vendu 70 sur la tête j'en suis
sûr enfin c'est tout de même bien toi
tout à l'heure qu'il est a dit il dit
non non comment je suis pas entré ici
tout à l'heure non tout est très malade
mais pas malade du grand troc cacher et
puis est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
que le mental
peut-être je crois que je suis assez
calme pour revoir flandre je crois en
bien et voilà
ferland s'est très mal ce que tu as fait
monter tiens tu n'as pas à ces affaires
dont on menace toutes occupées du mien
dure tant attendu par la population
selon la nature après le premier but on
cogne à 10 août on croit tout permis je
tenais raphaèle à tort santander mais le
premier qu'elle attend et c'est pas de
sa faute
ce qu'il ya de mauvais en elle c'est de
sa mère qu'elle est bien peur je ne peux
pas être fidèle
tu ne sois pas méchant oh non oui
sa mère n'était pas quand elle est
partie que nous a laissé tous les toits
et la flore et pendant quinze jours je
trais plus méchante je sois fidèle elle
fera tout ce qu'il pourra plus rapide
elle je serai fidèle alors brasco mari
voilà tu laisseras ton père tranquille 6
à la muse de garder notre coupe on
s'embrasse et là tout de même à la
maison embrasserait la maison à tête
reposée
ma première femme veut quitte pour un
tueur j'épouse moi comme mon fils est
amoureux de sa belle mère ma fille fait
des bêtises avec libye libre libre peut
pas le dire non plus mon gendre est
idiot quelle famille je sais ce que tu
vas me dire tu pas non on s'embrasse au
pauvre tu veux m'embrasser déjà
la pièce que nous voulons de jouer et de
marcel achard de l'académie française
la mise en scène et de jean meyer
les victoires de roger à
des costumes de donald k loisne
avec genre de grave
christiane muller
billets au teint
caroline silhol
jean françois calvet
yaël roman
jacques henri duval
madeleine robinson
richaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]